wir schalten jetzt mal live in unserer
heute show wahlstudio saarbrücken zu
albrecht humboldt und natürlich haben
wir uns den saarländischen gebräuchen
angepasst und auch unser studio in einem
fahrstuhl eingerichtet wenn ich da
direkt mal ein hafen dürfte die
arbeitsbedingungen hier die sind
wirklich ein problem
ich meine das ist ja hier nicht
irgendeine wahl überlegen sie mal was
das für eine signalwirkung hätte wenn
die merkel gleich die erste wahl des
jahres arbeiten albrecht am ende ist
halt nur das saarland
dafür braucht auch kein richtiges studio
auf nur das saarland
das ist ein weibchen hier ein kopf an
kopf rennen wenn wir dafür google gerade
die letzten umfragen aber auch wenn sie
das nicht begreifen wollen das hier ist
ein premium bundesland prozentual hat
das saarland leichten katholiken in
deutschland die höchste portdichte und
in der bundesregierung sitzen gleich
zwei saarländer der mars und der
altmaier also eigentlich sogar drei
altmaier verdoppelt das macht die wahl
aber auch nicht wirklich viel spannender
oder nein
hier droht am sonntag die erste rot rote
regierung in einem westdeutschen
flächenland biete air 2.0
dann wird ihr palla fontaine der
heimliche machthaber und wer es wiederum
der nur die marionette von der wortwahl
nicht hier von dieser stadt sind
natürlich immer es doch noch liebe und
pflegestufe 3 unsere kleine bundesland
hat die franzosen überlebt hat das ende
von kohle und stahl überlebt aber die
lafontaine werden kaputt krieg
das haben wir dann vom puls perfekt ich
prophezeie ihnen wenn die linke elf
hallo aber moment hallo
entschuldigung aber wir machen hier eine
live sendung ja sorry aber die
herrschaften waren ganz nach oben wir
müssen einen kleinen moment warten
[Applaus]